après la taxation des supports
numériques cd ou dvd notamment la
ministre de la culture catherine tasca
envisage de taxer tous les supports
d'enregistrement c'est à dire les
ordinateurs les consoles les futurs
décodeurs
ce qui n'est pas du goût des industriels
en quête daniel wolfromm miandry sera ce
consommateur de cassettes étaient taxés
depuis 15 ans sans qu'il ne le sache
trop mais depuis la technique numérique
permet le clonage de la musique ou des
images à l'infini le gouvernement va
donc taxer davantage ces nouveaux
supports
il en coûtera ainsi 3 francs 70 de plus
pour un minidisque la même chose 3
francs 70 de plus pour un cd audio 2
francs 15 pour un cd enregistreurs de
données un franc 87 pour une cassette
audio et de francs 80 de plus pour une
cassette vidéo
mais la ministre de la culture envisage
de taxer maintenant tous les matériels
d'enregistrement ordinateur magnétoscope
décodeur pour rétribuer les auteurs les
artistes et les producteurs
je dirais que cette taxe va compenser le
manque à gagner qui est dû au fait que
vous pouvez vous avez le droit de copier
de la musique gratuitement à pas
seulement vous avez acheté ce disque
vous avez le droit de copier
gratuitement cette musique pour les
industriels de l'électronique grand
public cette taxe n'est pas acceptable
nous pensons que cette taxe devra être
harmonisé au niveau européen et ne pas
provoquer de distorsion de concurrence
entre les différents pays à savoir que
par exemple une taxe sur les ordinateurs
en avant en allemagne d'environ 200
francs aura aujourd'hui dans les
premières discussions au sein de la
commission
on parle en france d'une taxe qui serait
entre 600 et 1000 francs
cette nouvelle taxe dès pas admise non
plus par les grands de la distribution
je pense que le gouvernement aurait
mieux fait de s'attaquer au problème à
la source c'est-à-dire par exemple en
faisant baisser le prix de la musique et
notamment en faisant baisser le prix de
la tva sur la musique qu'il n'est pas
normal que la musique soit taxée à 19,6
par exemple alors que le livre ou cinéma
sont taxés à 5 ennemis mais nul ne sait
précisément combien rapporterait cette
nouvelle redevance peut être un milliard
de francs la moitié pour les auteurs
compositeurs l'autre moitié pour les
chanteurs et la production